GOOD MORNING WILL BEGIN TODAY'S
HEARING ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY HERE CROW Là MON.
MEDINA HERE PURSUE CHANGE
O'DONNELL.
OBERNOLTE.
OKAY SIR IT WILL YEAH THERE.
THANK YOU TODAY'S OUR FINAL
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING.
APPLAUSE THERE MISTER MEDINA.
SO WE WE ARE WE'RE FINISHING.
FIFTY HOURS OF THAT TESTIMONY
THIS WINTER AND SPRING SO --
THANKS TO OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ALEJO AND ALL OF THE A
DEPARTMENTS FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION WITH THE WE HAD A
A ROBUSTHEARING PROCESS AND
WHEN I THINK OUR GOVERNOR FOR
HIS -- BUDGET PROPOSALS.
WE DIDN'T AGREE ON EVERYONE OF
THEM BUT THINK WE'RE LARGELY AT
ON THE SAME PAGE WITH THE
GOVERNOR.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT AND EARLY EDUCATION
PACKAGE WE'RE GOING TO GO OVER
TODAY.
I JUST WANT TO THANK OUR SOMEONE
MEMBERS WHO PARTICIPATES LIMóN
MEDINA -- Là MON -- MARZI CHINO
DONALD AS WELL AS MISTER
GALLAGHER MISTER BROWN TO AND
MISTER OPEN OBERNOLTE HEARING
THERE COLLUDING TODAY -- SO WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
THE THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS BEFORE
WE GET TO THAT THE MAIN ACTION
ITEMS OF TODAY SO WE WE HAVE THE
VOTE ONLY ITEMS ISSUES.
ONE THROUGH EIGHT ON PAGES TWO
THROUGH.
NINE LOOKING FOR A MOTION FOR
THESE SECOND PROP.
NINETY EIGHT BUT ONLY ITEMS
MOTION A SECOND -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MCCARTY BY.
PRO [inaudible]
THE MOUNT [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
O'DONNELL.
OBERNOLTE.
STRUCTURE WILL GO BACK AND YES
SO THROUGH THE END OF IT YEAH.
FIVE RECEPTIONS YES [inaudible]
SO.
OKAY SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO GET
TO THE OF PROP NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE WHICH INCLUDES K. TWELVE
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND IT
JUST.
HIGHLIGHT THAT TODAY IS A BIG
DAY FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
MR MEDINA AND MISTER MARTZ EACH
MISTER DONNA REMEMBERED AND I I
FORGOT SO FAR WHATEVER READ TIED
TO MY OFFICE WILL CHANGE A BIT
LATER TODAY AS I READ FOR AT ONE
FOCUS ON INVESTING IN IN -- OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IT'S NOT A PERFECT BUDGET
BUT I THINK WE MAKE --
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN OUR
BUDGET HERE TODAY WE OF COURSE
ADOPT THE THE GOVERNOR'S --
PROPOSAL FOR THE MAY REVISE FOR
FUNDING AND ADD A BIT MORE I TWO
MAJOR HIGHLIGHTS THAT WE THINK.
WILL HELP TREMENDOUSLY THROUGH --
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WITH A
CASH STRAPPED DISTRICTS ARE
FURTHER PAYING DOWN.
SOME OF OUR LIABILITIES IN
PENSION OBLIGATIONS SPECIFICALLY
IT AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION TO PAY DOWN THE PORTION
OF SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
CALPERS PENSION.
LIABILITIES ARE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA WHICH OF COURSE
GETS DISCRETIONARY MONIES TO OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WE WILL HAVE
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO
MILLION ON TOP OF THE GOVERNOR'S
NAY REVISED AMOUNT THAT'LL
FURTHER HELP.
OUR SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN WILL ALSO MAKE SURE WE
ADDRESS THE SPECIAL AT ISSUE
WHICH I KNOW MISTER MEDINA
O'DONNELL ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE SECOND.
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
NEARLY SIX HUNDRED MILLION
ONGOING FUNDING TO ADDRESS
SPECIAL LEAD -- WE HAVE A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT ALLOCATION OF
THOSE MONIES FOCUSING ON ABOUT
HALF THEIR EQUALIZATION WHICH I
THINK IS A FAIR WAY TO HELP
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE.
AS WELL AS SUPPORT THIS SPECIAL
LEAD -- EARLY EDUCATION
PRESCHOOL PROPOSAL.
WE ALSO PROVIDE FIFTY MILLION
ONE TIME AND FUNDING. FOR THE
LOW PERFORMING STUDENT BLOCK
GRANT -- A SLIGHT TWEAK OF THE
LC IF THAT PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE HELPING ALL CALIFORNIA
KIDS IN OUR IN OUR GREAT STATE
SO OVERALL -- YOU KNOW THIS IS A
POSITIVE INVESTMENT -- THEN.
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW MONEY FOR OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
BUT CERTAINLY NOT ENOUGH EVEN
AFTER THIS BUDGET WILL STILL BE.
IN THE FORTIES AND PER PEOPLE
FUNDING.
AND WE CERTAINLY HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO SO WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN.
PLOW MORE RESOURCES INTO OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA -- SO WITH THAT -- DO
WE HAVE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU WHEN A THANK ARE ARE
CHAIR -- FOR THE FIFTY TWO HOURS
THAT WE PUT IN.
ON THE BUDGET FOR EDUCATION.
AND AS HE INDICATED.
I AM WEARING RED FOR ED.
TODAY.
AT AS OUR THOUSANDS OF TEACHERS
ACROSS -- CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
HERE -- AT THE CAPITOL TODAY.
AND I AM PROUD TO HAVE BEEN.
A TEACHER IN THE CLASSROOM
TEACHER FOR THIRTY FOUR YEARS --
IN RIVERSIDE MY DISTRICT AND AND
AGREE WITH OUR CHAIR THAT THIS
IS NOT A PERFECT BUDGET -- AND
ALO AGREE WITH WITH THE MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE A MISTER
MURATSUCHI HERE -- WHO IS
POINTED OUT THAT BEING FORTY
FIRST I BELIEVE IN THE NATION --
IS NOT WHERE WE WANT TO BE -- I
I WAS A VERY -- PROUD TO HAVE
BEEN -- IN LA ON A RAINY DAY
WITH THE LA UNIFIED TEACHERS
WHEN THEY WALKED OUT.
WHEN THEY WENT ON STRIKE FOR A
FOR MORE FUNDING -- EN LA FOR
MORE LIBRARY AIDS MORE
LIBRARIANS MORE MENTAL HEALTH
WE'RE COUNSELORS.
AND WAS IMPRESSED WITH THE WITH
THE OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT THAT
THEY GOT IN LOS ANGELES.
OF THE PARENTS THAT WERE THERE --
SUPPORTING TEACHERS STUDENTS WHO
WERE THERE SUPPORTING THEIR
TEACHERS ALL SAYING THAT WE NEED
TO DO.
MORE AND BETTER FOR EDUCATION
FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION -- IN
CALIFORNIA.
ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
OF ON GOING -- PROP NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING FOR SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
FOR STUDENTS WITH SEVERE
DISABILITIES WOULD HAVE BEEN A
TWENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
A YEAR -- OVER A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD AND THAT IS NOT INCLUDED
SO I I HOPE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH MY COLLEAGUES.
TO DO BETTER. TO DO BETTER FOR
STUDENTS -- OWNED IN CALIFORNIA
WHO DESERVE THE SAME -- TOP
NOTCH EDUCATION THAT I THINK WE
HAD WHEN I I WAS GOING TO SCHOOL --
IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
INVESTMENT MEDINA.
THANK YOU -- THERE ARE --
CLEARLY.
BOB SIZE AND DOWNSIZE. TO ANY
BUDGET ARM.
ON THE UPSIDE I YOU'RE CERTAINLY.
APPRECIATE HOW -- THE GOVERNOR
TO BEGIN AND JANUARY RECOGNIZED
AND AND HEARD THE US SCHOOL
DISTRICTS -- BIGGEST CONCERNS
ABOUT THE THE BIGGEST COST
DRIVERS THAT WERE CHALLENGING
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
AND THAT.
WOULD BE PENSIONS AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
AND SO.
WHEN I?
STEP BACK AT WHAT.
TO OUR BUDGET IS LOOKING LIKE AT
THIS POINT -- ALTHOUGH I WAS
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE THAT THE
GOVERNOR WAS NOT PROPOSING.
A PLAN -- FOR GETTING CALIFORNIA.
FROM THE BOTTOM TEN IN THE
NATION IN PER PUPIL SPENDING --
TO GET US TO THE TOP.
OUR LEAST CLOSER TO THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
I I DID WRITE.
APPROVED ESPECIALLY APPRECIATE
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND NON
PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS THAT HE'S ALLOCATING TO
GIVE PENSION RELIEF TO OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHICH YOU KNOW.
CLEARLY ARE BECOMING A BIGGER
AND BIGGER CHALLENGE.
OF FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- I'M
HOPING THAT.
TO THESE DOLLARS I AM HEARING
FROM MY LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT THESE DOLLARS WILL
DEFINITELY.
GIVE THEM RELIEF -- TO TO
PROVIDE MORE FLEXIBILITY TO TO
SPEND MORE DOLLARS IN THE
CLASSROOM -- WITH THE DOLLARS
THAT WOULD BE FREED UP FROM --
THOSE THAT OTHERWISE WOULD BE
ALLOCATED -- TO TO THE THE
PENSION COSTS -- I ALSO -- VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION OF THE THE BUDGET.
THAT IS REJECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND TO FOCUS ON THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION CONCENTRATION GRANTS.
AND TO INSTEAD FOCUS THE DOLLARS
ON EQUALIZING SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING RATES -- I I BELIEVE
THIS IS A A FAIR WAY THAT WOULD
BENEFIT MORE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- AND FINALLY --
IT'S CHAIR I APPRECIATE
[inaudible]
TO THE THE INCLUSION OF THE ELSE
FF TARGET FUNDING -- GOALS --
THE THAT WE HAVE IN OUR VERSION
OF THE BUDGET -- SO THAT JUST
SAYS AS WE DID IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN WHEN WE HAD A PLAN.
ON HOW -- TO GET TO OUR END GOAL --
BETTER ACK IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
OR AND GOAL WAS TO RESTORE ALL
OF THE K. THROUGH -- TWELVE BUT
THE BUDGET CUTS THAT -- THAT WE
SUFFER DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION.
NOW WE SHOULD -- EXPIRED -- TO
YOU KNOW GET ARCHY ARE.
PEOPLE K. THROUGH TWELVE FUNDING --
BACK TO WHERE WE USED TO BE OR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD
BE -- IN THE TOP TEN IN THE
NATION AND I I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE.
TO THIS ONGOING EFFORT TO GET US
FROM THE BOTTOM -- BACK TO THE
TOP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER O'DONNELL.
YES SIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK
AND CERTAINLY -- YOUR STAFF YOUR
TEAM'S WORK.
BECAUSE A LOT OF THIS HAPPENS
OUTSIDE OF THIS HEARING AND I
REALIZE THAT SO I WANT TO THANK
THEM BOTH -- OF FOR THEIR THEIR
HELP ON THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR --
AND I WAS MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS
I TO SHARE MY COLLEAGUES
CONCERNS THAT WE'RE TREATING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT MORE OF
A MORE OF A FLOOR THEN.
IT MORE AND MORE AS A CEILING
AND FLOOR.
AND I THINK WHAT AT LEAST AT A
MINIMUM I THINK WE'VE STARTED
MISTER MURATSUCHI IF I MAY UM WE
START OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS
ASSURING KNOWLEDGE INSIDE THIS
HEARING WHEN PEOPLE COME UP.
AND THEY PAT THEMSELVES ON THE
BACK IS A WHILE WE FILL PROP.
NINETY EIGHT AND THEY WALK AWAY
BUT THAT'S NOT ENOUGH.
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR STILL ON
THE BOTTOM -- TEN ACROSS THE THE
COUNTRY -- JUST ANOTHER COUPLE
COMMON SPECIAL ED I WISH THAT WE
DO MORE FOR EQUALIZATION THAN WE
ARE RIGHT NOW.
I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE FROM --
RIVERSIDE IS AN ARDENT SUPPORTER
OF THAT -- AND ALSO THERE'S A
COMPONENT HERE WE'RE ACCEPTING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO SELL
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IN.
IN -- IN -- IN PROPOSITION FIFTY
ONE BOND FUNDS AND THEY WERE YOU
MY OPINION THAT WE SHOULD REALLY
TAKE THAT A CONFERENCE THAT
WOULD BE MY PREFERENCE I KNOW
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT TODAY BUT
WE MY PREFERENCE AT THAT GOES TO
CONFERENCE.
SO THAT WE CAN GET MORE BOAT
BOND SOLD AND WE CAN GET MORE --
SCHOOLS MODERNIZED BUILT INVEST
IN OUR KIDS WITH THAT I TURN IT
BACK TO YOU MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR O'DONNELL WITH WHAT WE DID --
LOOK AT THAT ISSUE AND WE'RE IN
FULL AGREEMENT THAT THE VOTERS
VOTED FOR THAT.
THAT BOND MEASURE AND WHAT THE
MONEY SPENT.
TO MODERNIZE AND AND BUILD
CLASSROOMS ACROSS CALIFORNIA WE
DIDN'T QUITE.
BUDGET THE DEBT SERVICE FOR THAT
ACCORDINGLY SO THAT'S AN ISSUE
THAT YOU KNOW WE CAN WE CAN TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT STILL AND
CONFERENCE EVERYTHING'S ALWAYS
ON THE TABLE.
HI I DIDN'T GO OVER AND THIS IS
THE WHOLE PROP NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE HERE TODAY.
TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE PAY
SOME HIS CAR KIND OF BRIEFLY
OUTLINED SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS
OF THAT AS WELL IF IF
INDIVIDUALS WANT -- TO PIPE IN
OR HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THAT
BEFORE TAKE THE VOTE SO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE -- PROP NINETY
EIGHT PACKAGE HE IS A BIT MORE
AS A SAID FROM THE OUTSET THEN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AND I BELIEVE IN THE SENATE AS
WELL SO.
WE'RE PLEASE AS FAR AS OUR
INVESTMENTS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS
THIS YEAR IS WERE FOCUSING ON
OUR CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM.
WHICH WILL PROVIDE FREE TUITION
FOR TWO YEARS FOR FIRST TIME
FULL TIME STUDENTS WE THINK
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL FOR STUDENTS
HOPING TO GRADUATE DEBT FREE.
AND ALSO GET MORE STUDENTS IN
THE COMMUNICANTS SYSTEM TO FILL
THE JOBS OF TODAY.
AND TOMORROW AS FAR AS THAT THE
THE FORMULA -- THE NEW FUNDING
FORMULA FOR FOR OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES -- IN SOME IT'S IT'S A
BIG MESS RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE
THE TIME -- NOR THE ANSWERS TO
COME UP WITH A SOLUTION TODAY
WHAT WE'RE DOING IN THE INTERIM
HE IS -- LOCKING IN THEIR
PERFORMANCE FUNDING AT 10%.
AND URGING ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE CHANCES OFFICE AND
ADMINISTRATION TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THE FORMULA BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE PROBABLY TEN
OR FIFTEEN DIFFERENT IDEAS OF
PROPOSALS HOW TO ADDRESS THIS
AND THAT DOESN'T GIVE US -- YOU
KNOW FRANKLY A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO SO AT THIS
POINT TIME WE KNOW THERE'S
THERE'S BAD DATA DISAGREEMENTS
OVER THE DEFINITIONS.
AND OF COURSE AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER DOZENS OF RECOMMENDATION
SO.
AT THIS POINT WE'RE UNSURE HOW
TO PROCEED SO WE'RE JUST FUNDING
THE BASE AMOUNT AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THEN
ADDRESSING THE PERFORMANCE ISSUE
AT 10% SO.
THAT WERE KIND OF A PUNTING ON
FOR A FUTURE DAY.
AS FAR AS THE ONLINE COLLEGE WE
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT IS --
THE LOG IN THE POLICY FROM LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET.
AND WE RESPECT THAT AND WE'RE
INTERESTED SEE HOW THAT.
PLAYS OUT.
IN THE COMING MONTHS -- AND IN
YOUR HEAD HOWEVER WE THINK THAT
IT WAS OVER BUDGET AND IN THE ON
GOINGAND ONE TIME AMOUNTS
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE LOOK AT OTHER --
PRIORITIES IN OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM -- FOCUSING ON
STUDENTS IN NEED -- AND OTHER
AREAS WHERE WE COULD FIND --
PRIORITIES IN OUR STATE BUDGET
WHICH INCLUDE -- FACULTY.
VETERAN RESOURCE CENTER A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS LIKE --
PLENTY IN A MùT JOB.
AND HAS A MUCH EARLIER -- FOR
FULL TIME FACULTY ISSUES AND
PART TIME FACULTY OFFICE HOURS
SO.
THAT IS -- HIGHLIGHTS OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE -- BUDGET
PACKAGE.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
MR MEDINA I'M JUST GLAD THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE ON
GOING -- CONCERN OF THE THE
LARGE NUMBER OF PART TIME
FACULTY AND AND AND THE KIND OF
SECOND CLASS -- STATUS A PART
TIME FACULTY AND I THINK WE DID
SOME OF THAT IN THE BUDGET AND
ALSO.
A CONTINUE TO WORK ON INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF FULL TIME FACULTY.
OKAY SING NUMBER COMMENTS ON ON
THE PROP NINETY EIGHT PIECE WHAT
I'M LOOKING FOR IS A MOTION ON
THE ENTIRE PACKAGE.
AND THEN -- AFTERWARDS WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOW.
MISTER OBERNOLTE MISTER BRO TO
TO PULL OFF SOME OF THE ITEMS IF
THEY WANT -- TO RECORD THEIR
VOTES ACCORDINGLY SO -- I'M
LOOKING FOR A MOTION A SECOND.
THIS MOVE BY MR O'DONNELL SECOND
BY MISTER MEDINA -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MCCARTY HI GROW.
LIMON I MEDINA FIVE FIRST TWO GB
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
OKAY.
AND AGAIN WE'LL COME BACK WITH
THOSE EXCEPTIONS TO MISTER.
BROWN OBERNOLTE AT THE
CONCLUSION -- FINALLY WE HAVE
OUR EARLY EDUCATION.
PACKAGE WHICH IS A COMBINATION
OF PROP NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND.
AND SPECIAL FUNDS IN THIS IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
VERY PROUD.
OF OUR PROPOSAL HERE BEFORE US
TODAY WE KNOW THAT -- TO MAKE IT
SIMPLE EARLY EDUCATION MATTERS
PRE K. MATTERS -- CHILD CARE
MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN AND
PARENTS LIVES TRYING TO GET TO
WORK AND ALSO.
THE THE OF WELL BEING -- KIDS
ARE THREE FIVE IN OUR GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT -- THAT WE
COULD -- YOU COULD DO -- THAT
CUTS OF THE GREAT RECESSION ARE
STILL STINGING IN THESE PROGRAMS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
SO WE HAVEN'T.
FULLY BEEN ABLE TO RESTORE THAT --
BUT WE'VE LOOKED AT WHAT'S
NEEDED AS FAR AS A AS A SMART
PATH FORWARD YOU KNOW THE
ASSEMBLY JUST ANNOUNCED OUR BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION ON EARLY
EDUCATION OUR FINDINGS AND WE
TAKE A LOT OF THAT WORK AND
INCLUDE THAT.
IN OUR PLAN HERE TODAY I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
LED BY OUR OUR COLLEAGUE HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE.
HONESTLY MON -- HELPED US PUT
FORWARD SOME RECOMMENDATIONS
WHICH ARE INCLUDED IN THIS PROP
IN THIS PACKET SOME OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS INCLUDE.
AN ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED
THIRTEEN MILLION ABOVE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR
CHILDCARE SLOTS THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO THE TEN THOUSAND
FULL DAY PRESCHOOL SLOTS THAT
WERE IN THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET -- SO OF WHICH HUNDRED
AND SIXTY SIX MILLION WILL GO
FOR ALTERNATE PAYMENT SLOTS FOR
PER CHILD CARE PROVIDERS A
HUNDRED MILLION THROUGH OUR
GENERAL CHILD CARE PROGRAM.
AND FORTY SEVEN MILLION FROM FOR
OUR EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM FOR FOSTER CHILDREN
AGAIN THIS IS ON TOP OF THE TEN
THOUSAND FULL DAY PRESCHOOL
SLOTS. FOR NON L. EA PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE -- IN IN THE IN OUR
BUDGET THEY WERE LOOKING FORWARD
TO ROLLING OUT IN THE IN THE
COMING MONTHS.
HOW WE ALSO IMPROVE -- ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS FOR CHILD CARE
FACILITIES AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT -- AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S -- FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROPOSAL WEEK WE
ADJUSTED THAT SLIGHTLY IN THE
PRIOR -- A MEASURE IN A PROP
NINETY EIGHT BUT SOME OF THOSE
FUNDS WILL ALSO BE.
UTILIZED TO EXPAND -- ELLIE A
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS -- IN
ADDITION WE PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
FOCUS ON THE RATE STRUCTURE WE
KNOW THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
ONLY VIABLE IF THEY'RE
FINANCIALLY VIABLE ECONOMICALLY
VIABLE THAT INCLUDES MAKING SURE
WE WE PAY THE WORKERS --
ADEQUATE WAGES WE TALKED OVER
AND OVER THAT TO ME THESE
WORKERS.
ESSENTIALLY GET PAID FAST FOOD
WAGES AND LITERALLY QUALIFY FOR
THE PROGRAMS THAT THEY'RE
WORKING AND SO -- OUR RATE
REFORM ISSUE ADDRESSES THAT BUT
ALSO IMPROVES QUALITY STANDARDS
TO HELP MAKE SURE THE PROGRAMS
HELP OUR KIDS AS WELL.
AND THEN LAST LASTLY WE DO A
SLIGHT -- TWEAK OF THE
GOVERNOR'S -- PROP SIXTY FOUR
FUNDING THAT'S THE THE OF COURSE
THE MARIJUANA AT TAX REVENUE
COMING IN -- WE THINK IT WAS
CRYSTAL CLEAR THE VOTERS WANTED
TO TAX AND REGULATE MARIJUANA IN
CALIFORNIA AND USE THE MONIES
FOR PROGRAMS LIKE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS THAT'S LITERALLY WHAT
THE TV COMMERCIAL ON BALLOT
ARGUMENTS STATED SO.
WE'RE GOING -- TO ADJUST THAT
ALLOCATION ACCORDINGLY AND FIND
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS FOUR ACES
PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE MORE.
VIABLE THROUGHOUT THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO THAT'S A
SNAPSHOT OF OUR OF OUR PACKAGING
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY.
I PLEASE WITH OUR OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS THIS MORNING.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS MISS
LIMóN.
THANK YOU AT CHAIR AND I DO WANT
TO ECHO SOME OF YOUR SENTIMENTS
I THINK THAT IT'S CLEAR THAT --
THIS BUDGET -- TO SUPPORTS
WORKING FAMILIES -- WITH THE
INVESTMENT OF A MORE THAN HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS FOR OUR EARLIEST
LEARNERS I THINK THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW AND IT'S ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
IS ONGOING -- AT CARE FOR OUR
EARLIEST EARNERS LEARNERS IS NOT
A ONE TIME THING -- IT REQUIRES
A YEAR TO YEAR INVESTMENT AND
THIS BUDGET DOES HAVE ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THAT -- AND WE'VE
ALSO AND NOT LEFT ASIDE SOME OF
THE NEEDS TO SERVE THE EARLIEST
LEARNERS RELATED TO
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND A THINK.
NOT LAST THINKING OF THE THE THE
THE CHILDREN WHERE THAT THE
CENTERS ARE FACILITIES OF WHERE
THEY'RE AT THE ALSO OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK IN THIS
SPACE -- OUR INVESTMENT -- IN
THE WORK FORCE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT AND SO I KNOW THAT THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS A CHAMPION.
TO THESE ISSUES FOR OR YEARS AND
YEARS AND YEARS AND ON BEHALF OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS WE ARE HAPPY
TO SEE THAT SOME OF OUR
PRIORITIES MADE IT TO THIS
BUDGET.
SO THANK YOU ADD TO THE
COMMITTEE AND TO THE MEMBERS FOR
SUPPORTING THAT [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU AND AND THANK YOU FOR
HIGHLIGHTING THAT AGAIN IT'S
IT'S OVER -- HALF A BILLION ON
GOING AND IT'S OVER -- A BILLION
IF YOU LOOK AT THAT THE ONE TIME
RESOURCES FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND SOME OF THE DECISIONS
FOR FOR MARS SO.
YEAH AND SOME THIS WILL MAKE A
HUGE DIFFERENT FOR OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS AND OUR FAMILY SO WE
KNOW -- EARLY EDUCATION IS A
PROVEN DIFFERENCE MAKER -- FOR
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP FOR
THAT BREAKING -- CYCLES OF
POVERTY SPECIFICALLY
INTERGENERATIONAL POVERTY AND
FOR A DRESSING ARE THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE ISSUE SO -- THESE
INVESTMENTS NOLLIE MATTER FOR
PARENTS AND FAMILIES BUT FOR OUR
ISSUES OF THE DAY WE'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO -- WITH THAT LOOKING FOR A
MOTION ON THE EARLY EDUCATION
AND AFTER SCHOOL PACKAGE.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY I PRO -- LIMON.
MEDINA BY FIRST TO CHANGE
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
OKAY THAT -- CONCLUDES OUR
ACTIONS FOR TODAY.
AGAIN OUR OURACTION ITEMS ARE
IN THE BACK ALSO ON OUR WEB PAGE
ONE TAKE A LOOK AND THANKS
EVERYBODY FOR PARTICIPATING IN
THIS YEAR'S SUBCOMMITTEE.
PROCESS SO WE WANT TO DO SOME
ADD ONS RIGHT NOW AND THEN WE'LL
DO THE VOTE CHANGES -- WE'RE
DOING ALL THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS
AND THE MAN [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU SO.
MISTER -- BRO AND OBERNOLTE IF
YOU IN A WALK THROUGH YOUR YOUR
CHANGES FOR THE PACKAGE PLEASE
DO SO NOW.
I'LL GO FIRST IF YOU DON'T MIND
SO FOR THE VOTE ONLY ONES WERE
YOU BOTH.
OKAY AND ALL THE VOTE ONLY ONCE
VOTE ONLY ISSUE.
FOR NO.
OKAY [inaudible]
MR BRO.
ON THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY SO THAT'S ABOUT ALL THE
ITEMS AND THIS AND WE'RE GONNA
GO NOW TO THE OVERALL PROP --
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE.
SO PLEASE INDICATE THE ITEMS
THAT YOU WISH TO VOTE NO ON
THEIR SIXTY ONE ITEM SO YOU CAN
JUST.
CALL UP THE ONE START WITH YOU
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THIS IS AN ISSUE.
ONE YES ISSUE ONE THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE
[inaudible]
NUMBER -- TWO NUMBER
EIGHT THE BILL [inaudible] FORTY
SEVEN THE ONE TO SIXTY ONE
THAT'S A VERY [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
MR BRO -- FIVE WELL -- AB
[inaudible] ONE TO SECTION OF
OKAY.
WE HAVE A CLARIFICATION FOR ME
YES -- INTO YES.
OKAY.
YEAH I THOUGHT SO.
IT'S A GOOD.
ONE YES YES.
OKAY NOW WILL GO TO ISSUE TO OUR
EARLY EDUCATION AND AFTER SCHOOL
PACKAGE DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADJUSTMENTS -- FOR THIS MR
OBERNOLTE [inaudible] ONE CREWS
[inaudible] FOR SEVEN WELL --
OKAY KNOWS YOU'RE VOTING NO.
ONE OKAY [inaudible]
MISTER BROWN [inaudible] THREE
SO THAT [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible] FORTY OKAY
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
AND WITH THAT WE WILL ADJOURN
THANK YOU